attorneys for a construction company and
the owners of the MSG sphere were in
court today fighting over millions of
dollars reporter Joshua peguero has
video from several Court proceedings in
its story you will only see right here
on eight
over the last few years we've been back
and forth in court over MSG sphere in
the construction company writer 11
Bucknell Ryder Levis says it's being
sipped of 3.1 million dollars an
assertion that parent company of MSG
sphere is pushing back against we know
he made this decision affecting us we
know who made the decision to stop
paying us and we know who made who's
behind the counter claims he it's it's
but it's stolen himself James Dolan is
the Chief Executive Officer of MSG which
owns the New York Knicks New York
Rangers and Madison Square Garden this
hearing happened in May before judge
Nancy Alf inside Clark County District
Court MSG Spears attorneys rebuked any
notion Dolan is signaling out writer
Levitt he thinks Mr Dolan did all these
things that's his speculation but what
he hasn't done in the intervening time
is taken any other depositions Ryder
Levitz attorneys want to take a
deposition from Dolan they argue this
would approve he doesn't want to pay
them the 3.1 million dollars nonetheless
the court hearings are shining on light
into what may have led to the paid
dispute there was supposed to be the
longest bar in this in this project and
they built it and then he came through
and deleted and wanted to take it out
increase in Project cost Mr Dolan's
decision
against advice
increase the project cost and now he's
blaming us msg's attorneys responded to
those claims in court saying there's no
proof Dolan had knowledge the spear is
expected to open in the fall of this
year at a cost of 2.3 billion dollars
the band U2 would be the opening act
there's also another lawsuit involving
construction on the MSG sphere in that
lawsuit developers suing the former
general contractor claiming they're owed
nearly 2 million dollars Joshua peguero
eight news now
now we can also tell you that sphere
entertainment which is a subsidiary of
MSG previously sent us a statement that
reads in part this story has no merit
the filings clearly show writer Levitt
Bucknell was fired for cause